in China you can find a good Factory
that treats its workers right but you
can also go find a place that is like
straight up slave labor the textiles to
use organic or regenerated Fabrics that
might cost anywhere from double to like
five times just to buy the product
before you ever sew it there was a long
in the states if you import something
that's basically more healthy not
sprayed with this chemical you don't get
a tax break but you get like a 20 or 30%
tax break on something that's been
sprayed with the chemical that actually
comes off when you wash the clothing wow
there's been some strange lobbying
happen in this part of the world where
do you Source everything what country we
do our jeans in Vietnam and it's the
cleanest denim Factory in the world 98%
of the dyes that are used are recycled
they don't just get dumped into a river
like in China you there's a lot of
rivers that are literally Blue from
having all the denim dumped into the
rivers I left Quicksilver after
23 years and uh started my own brand
outerknown and I wanted to do recycled
regenerated or organic Fabrics